he thinks that he's doing some kind of a
service to islam
yeah and these people are deranged i've
come across a lot of them
i've had personal experiences with these
kind of individuals they're deranged
assalamu alaikum guys hope you guys are
well welcome back to my channel
as you guys know yesterday there was an
attack done by isis
uh once again a cowardly cowardly act
uh targeting innocent civilians going
about their life
just as the far right who did the same
attack in australia
this was done in austria but the other
one was done in australia
i mean sorry new zealand uh where a
far-right maniac went into
a mosque and start killing innocent
muslims
and this scumbag dirtbag that we can
hear who thinks he's a big man
uh with his uh big biceps uh big knife
and
kalashnikov thinks he's some kind of a
hero in islam
and he's under the delusion that he
thinks that him killing innocent people
is somehow
he has a belief that he's going to stand
in front of god and god's going to say
well done he has paradise for you or
more like
get the hell into hell you scumbag now
this
this guy is i'm so sorry i'm going to
make it very clear he's a muslim yes
a deranged muslim um and people like him
are the reason why we have attacks
against muslims and our prophet being
insulted and attacked here when the
attack was happening
this dirt bag i'm so sorry i'm going to
put him as a isis scum dirtbag
swearing i swear to allah you haven't
seen anything from us just yet yeah he
thinks
he's a big man going killing innocent
people makes him really tough
we have prepared for britain what never
crossed your mind i promise
you know and now they want to start
trouble in the united kingdom
and when these kind of attacks happen uh
brothers and sisters
if you see these quotes do you think
he's going to use this course do you
think we muslims orthodox muslims who
practice their religion and pray you
know
um do you think we're going to be using
these uh tweets we will put fear in you
and terrorize you even in your dreams
when you are asleep
blood for blood just wait for our
surprises hahaha alhamdulillah
this coward he thinks that he's doing
some kind of a service to islam
yeah and these people are deranged i've
come across a lot of them
i've had personal experiences with these
kind of individuals they're deranged
they want a belonging they are they come
from a troubled background and even
there was some recent study
not studies there was a something
released by the mi5 that two of these
guys who went to join isis actually
bought a book called dummies
uh muslim for dummies or something like
that yeah or islam for dummies
and these guys are exactly that guys
they have gone out there killings in a
killing spree
and shooting innocent people walking by
now the
question that needs to be asked is are
these people
who are they serving do you think when
they carry out these attacks
they are honoring the prophet muhammad
peace be upon him do you think they are
making people more inclined to know
learn more about islam do you think they
are making people be like you know what
this religion of islam
we would like to know more about it
sounds so good who benefits from their
attacks
nobody but islamophobes nobody but
people individuals the far-right the
neo-nazis those
individuals are the ones who benefit out
of this
because they use this to further push
the agenda just as i interviewed tommy
robinson's friend kailyn
he testified and said that tommy
robinson would actually be happy
when he would hear his attacks and i
don't blame him and i said you know what
i know he does
why because it supports the agenda and
it's a tip for tap
isis and the far right are buddies i've
said this before
i'll say again when a certain attack
happens they
benefit from each other when isis
carrying attacked the fire and say see
we need to get islam out of europe
when um the far-right attack is to say
there you go they're attacking us
and that's the reason why this coward uh
tweeted blood for blood
or god knows what most likely because of
that now i want to
say something as an orthodox muslim i
practice my religion i'm not a coward
like these guys who think
that they don't do the basis of their
religion they can just go out there and
get
killed in the process of killing others
and think they're going to be a martyr
you are nothing but an absolute
coward you're living in a land where
you're residing and you are waging war
wage war innocent civilians
and the prophet peace be upon him told
us that the lowest form of faith
is to move a harmful object from the
world now if i was in a situation
where i had i was armed with a gun and i
happened to be in that very place in
vienna
what do you think my religion teaches me
to do to silently
watch this guy kill innocent people and
be like that's got nothing to do with me
what does my religion say to me that i
have to take act if i
have the means by the way guys i'm not
asking anyone to be a superhero yeah
but if i had the means yeah i would have
no shadow of a doubt i have no shadow of
doubt that to
take this guy down to save innocent
people's lives is a part of
islam this is what islam teaches when
allah said but if you save a single soul
it's as if you save the whole of
humanity
and this is the reason why the prophet
muhammed peace be upon him spoke so
harshly against this individual
this group called this is who these
people are
they go out there and kill in the name
of islam they look like us they talk
like us they walk like us
and when they do these attacks who are
who who gets the
backlash innocent muslims going about
their lives getting their hijabs ripped
off their faces
spattered beaten or even murdered in
cold blood
and that is the reason why we need to
step up against these individuals
and brothers and sisters i urge you guys
if you know anybody who is deranged
go to the authorities do go
to the authorities these people are the
reason why our religion
has been attacked but on a positive note
these two men
these two brothers here uh are the two
turkish individual muslims
who actually um helped a lady who was
shot
um and one of them actually got shot
themselves with a
shotgun and they managed to save a
police officer in the process
now the question that needs to be asked
is the following these two
men are muslim yeah
now this other guy claims to be a muslim
now which one do you think the far right
and isis would call a real muslim i'll
be honest with you isis would look at
these two and think
these guys are absolute they're
apostates they're not even real muslims
guess what the far right will say they
would agree with them and say
damn right these guys are not your
muslims and when you turn to the
this isis dirt back here and we asked
them
and we asked isis i said this is a real
muslim
guess what the far-right would say the
pharah would admit the same thing and
say yes
he is a true representation of islam and
you see the hypocrisy
when it's muslims doing something good
and saving their lives in that process
the media will not touch upon that they
are you know
seen as turks you know they will not be
mentioned as muslims
you know um but when the perpetrator is
a muslim you know is anything to do with
that oh islam
straight away so brothers and sisters
and those who are watching this want to
make something very clear
we are totally against these individuals
these guys are the biggest enemies and
the prophet peace be upon him have told
us
that how harshly we should be with these
individuals that if
the prophet said if i was to live at
their time i would destroy them as
god has destroyed ad allah god almighty
destroyed nations before
the prophet peace be upon him said that
he would destroy these people because
the
covet they cause to everybody and
society at large
and especially muslims so this was just
a little reminder video from me
to you guys and let us inshallah um make
uh awareness to this and share with your
friends and family as well and
non-muslims
to show that you know what if you're
going to call
this individual and we're not saying
he's not a muslim and by the way we're
not seeing this individual
uh this individual who carried that he's
not muslim he's a deranged individual
but these two individuals served islam
and done the teaching of a muslim what
islam teaches
more than this absolute uh scum of this
earth
who thinks that he can go out there kill
innocent people and be shot in the
process and think he's going to have a
free pass to paradise
more like a free pass to hell um
anyways guys until next time assalamu
alaikum